tasty has challenged me to make a recipe
that's gone through Google translate 50
times and at the end we'll see how well
I do this is not going well step one
it's a hot summer 400 cover it with foil
oil preheat the oven to 400 is what I'm
going to do baking sheet as my foil oil
12 barrels of coal add one cup por and
one cup of water to the pan squeeze out
the sand and stir 15 I don't understand
12 barrels of coal Oreos mom help I'm
changing my boil oil to a pan I'm going
to add one cup of Buttermilk and one cup
of water put this overheat till it
becomes a Sandy texture arrange flowers
in rows holes in each flow flour dough
we're going to arrange them in a row now
I'm going to add holes to them mix mix
quar cup melted butter with half
teaspoon powdered sugar this feels a
little too straightforward I'm going to
do it